like in in hebrew you say like by your
feet
you have to experience it yourself you
have to push yourself to your limits and
understand that like
there's more that you can do you don't
have to succumb to the stress pressure
whatever's in front of you at the moment
[Music]
nuri golan thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders how are you
today
i'm good how are you i i'm doing great
i'm very jealous of you you get to
meet julian gil on an ongoing basis and
i miss them so much ever since i came
back to israel for the covet times
so please send them my my love and my
regards
but enough about them nuri uh such a
fascinating journey that you've taken
and perhaps one of the most fascinating
pieces of it is right in the beginning
as a captain in the in the israeli navy
seals
turning into running r d for that same
unit and then
and then you know the boring stuff
selling a company and creating another
startup sitting on advisory boards but
that's the boring stuff
let's let's go back to the beginning
nori how do you get to be a combat
officer in the navy seals
uh lots of reasons for for wanting to do
that but
but most importantly you know i grew up
in a very zionist family a lot of a lot
of my uncles and my dad all served in
the israeli military
uh so when i was when i was a teenager i
started to think about it and then
i actually was was in israel during the
second lebanon war in 2006 and it was it
was a really
interesting experience being there is i
think it was 19 at the time
uh and everyone your age is kind of out
at war
and so being there and having a good
time in tel aviv but not seeing anybody
your age really has an impact on you and
someone who
always kind of thought about wanting to
to serve and do something a little bit
bigger than me
uh that was the the kind of the straw
that brought broke the camel's back and
i
i decided i wanted to uh join the
israeli military
so i finished my degree uh so i was
studying at george washington university
at the time
uh aerospace oh wow so i spent another
two years
uh completing my my degree and then in
2008 i got in a plane with uh with my
cousin
uh and the two of us made aliyah and uh
and joined and then i i thought i was
only going to go for two years
and then come back to the u.s but i got
it
at nine yeah i i
i got accepted to the navy seal entry
exam
and on my way there somebody told me you
know this is
at least five year service and i said i
didn't know that but okay
um and once i passed and they they
admitted me and invited me to start
training i
i just couldn't give up the opportunity
no i have to say that
uh you know i'm sure that a lot of my
friends in as well who are going to be
listening to this are already getting
frustrated because
like you know it's it's known how
insanely difficult it is to get accepted
to the navy seals you know the gaboush
is one of the most notorious
difficult experiences that any uh you
know young 18
or 17 year olds can go through and
getting accepted there is remarkable and
i'm sure that it's quite a big shock
also coming from
university studying aerospace
engineering and landing all of a sudden
in this
five six year program where you're
literally you know drinking sea water
and eating sand
uh talk to me a little bit about this
experience of going from george
washington university
straight into the navy seals
um well it's definitely a shock
um there were there were many moments
where i stood there i think
one of the during one during the
five-day entry exam the bush
um at one point it was like there was a
lightning storm out and they were
making us running out of the water and i
was holding this giant like metal
anchor and they told me to go throw it
in the water so we could go like run
around it in circles
and i'm like looking up at the sky like
thinking i'm about to get hit by
lightning carrying this giant thing what
the hell am i doing here
how did i get here but um you know like
at the time again i was i was at 21 at
the time i was
you know locked in focused this is what
i wanted to do and so you know that that
kind of takes over
any of the critical thinking parts of
your brain and you just kind of run with
it
it's definitely a challenge for me at
least like some of the most challenging
parts weren't necessarily the physical
uh pieces but but dealing with you know
having
officers and commanders who were younger
than me uh who didn't really have a ton
of life experience you know that it was
really funny like i had a degree again i
wasn't exactly like the most mature and
sophisticated person in the world but
i had a degree engineering degree and
people are looking at me like i'm only
going to start my college in like five
or six years after i finish the military
go travel for two years take a year off
so that for me was one of the one of the
most difficult parts
uh the physical stuff so just just for
context i want to i want to move forward
on your journey just so that we can get
the context as to what is to
the type of person you are but then i
really want to circle back and go back
to these
extraordinary lessons that one can learn
in the in the combination because the
truth be told
most of israelis in the tech scene
especially those that are in silicon
valley they they're not
coming from these from these elite
combat units a lot of them are coming
from
you know 8200 81 all those elite
technological units
and so i'm extremely excited to to hear
your perspective on the different
leadership lessons but walk me through
some of the different experiences you
had
like with er with exo that was acquired
by lear
and then sitting on advisory boards in
your most recent startup
are you asking about those experiences
specifically or yeah
give me the rundown of what happened
since you left just so that we can get
the context
so i i finished my service and i always
like
startup world and entrepreneurship was
something that was always
interesting to me and i ended up doing
my mba at the technion which had a
startup and innovation program casualty
yeah um and so that kind of is where
everything started they basically tell
you like you should
start a company and use this as like a
incubator for
you know to to build your idea out and
so i was lucky enough to meet a couple
partners
one of which was was the the guy who led
the gps
squadron in the u.s air force so
he had some ideas about how to improve
the accuracy of gps
obviously that was like okay this could
be a very big deal and so we started a
company around it
um and yeah like the the the lessons and
the training that you get in the
military
in my opinion are are some of the best
that an entrepreneur can get like you're
right
when i go around in silicon valley
pitching the vcs they ask me oh like
were you in the 8200 were you in 8-1
where you know they already know those
buzzwords and
i was like oh no i wasn't 13. they're
like what's that i'm like
end of the spectrum but i i think that
you know like
you're used to working the training that
you do you're used to working under
serious time constraints never knowing
what like the next
minute is going to be let alone the next
like week or month
um you know intense conditions
everything's up and down and you have to
learn to keep yourself kind of really
level-headed
and so i think like the the the best
entrepreneur
lessons i ever learned were in the
training that i got in the military and
i think that that helped me you know
through exo where we're trying to sell a
deep tech
company or a deep technology product to
a lot of to like the automotive industry
uh which was at the time you know and
still a very difficult industry to sell
into especially for startups
um you you have a lot of highs and lows
and being able to manage that is
is one of the most critical parts of
running a early stage startup
right so you've done that you've done
that once you're doing it again now it's
a savio
what what is the cbo so cecilio is uh
a autonomous cloud native platform so it
helps you manage your
uh it's like a next generation
observability tool for managing your
your online and cloud native services
and so we help any company of any size
generally
some of the larger companies that are
moving into the cloud more and more so
uh keep their applications running and
keeping their environments optimized
so so it sounds like it definitely
sounds like something that's necessary
to do but what is the problem because
you know from most people's perspective
we look at all the big
the big tech companies that we have
today obviously they're running in the
cloud and obviously every startup is
starting out in the cloud
i think people will quickly forget that
the majority of the world is not in the
cloud
i don't know exactly what percentage
maybe you can enlighten me but but i
still believe that
a lot of the of the you know big core
enterprises that we've seen you know
that we've rolled in from the 20th
century have yet to make that transition
am i right
well yeah i mean cloud is just also one
of those terms that
you don't know exactly what you mean
like yeah cloud a lot of people today
they think that means you're running on
aws
or google or azure but really like
anything that where you're running an
application not on your own computers
is cloud technically right like you're
running something somewhere else
and to do that you have to use a ton of
different softwares and services and
tools to help keep it running smoothly
and so where observability is one piece
of that world which is just helping keep
your
your services up and running like
everyone's had the experience where
they're using a
an application it could be a banking app
on your phone and it just crashes on you
like why did that happen you know it's
not that why does it happen only once
out of 100 times well there could be a
number of circumstances in how the
environment is operating
where you know in that one moment when
enough people are using it the system
crashes and so what we do is we're able
to
figure out much earlier before those
failures materialize like what's going
on and whether or not something's going
to happen
so we predict it ahead of time and help
you make sure it doesn't doesn't
affect your customers experience wow so
so and where are you at with that
journey right now so i know that you're
a part of upwest labs
a phenomenal phenomenal group and but
but what what's what's been the journey
like for cecilia
yeah i mean the company was started
earlier this year um
and i and uh me and and one of my
co-founders from exo and and then
named adam and then obviously ron or the
other two co-founders started it up we
raised a little bit of money we're
we're out raising money again right now
which is always a fun process
uh and starting you know starting to to
build it out we have a
core product that's that's being
released and we're working with a number
of partners already so it's it's very
exciting time
this is that and and what's been the
most what's been the most
the biggest learning experience or the
learning curve that you had to adapt to
as you're transitioning because in one
it is very different from everything
else you've done right i understand
coming from a military background when
we we still have to talk about the
leadership experiences that you've
gained
there but i understand that the
technical background you've gained there
the gps deep technology military
application
makes a lot of sense and now you're
moving on to helping big enterprises
make it
transition towards the cloud world with
predictive analysis
on on when things might go wrong it
doesn't connect in my mind
help me work this out i mean
you don't always have to be the industry
expert
yourself to to run a successful business
or startup i think that you know there's
there's a lot of other factors you
talked about like
leadership right like having someone who
can just steer the ship in the right way
and know how to build the company in the
right way and
bring in the right people and the right
experience the right talent
that's critically important and so this
is a brand new space for me which is a
challenge and it's actually a challenge
that i embraced it you know i was i was
excited about
trying something new and not just
staying in the same field for the rest
of my life
for me like what i want to do is i want
to continuously build companies and
and learn one of the one of the coolest
things about doing this is that you get
to learn a whole new space and you get
to learn
a whole new world of technology a whole
new world of people
uh and that's that to me is exciting so
it's not it's not that this there's a
direct connection between gps and cloud
services it's more that
uh the the recipe for building a good
startup is is pretty much the same no
matter what industry you're in
and it sounds to me like a key
ingredient all the way from
studying aerospace and in george
washington to
going to the navy seals to running r d
in the navy seals to selling a gps
company to now doing this is curiosity
i mean it sounds like you're just
passionate about whatever you're doing
you're embracing that challenge you
mentioned before when you were just
doing that that you're you're sort of
trained your
train your mind to to stop that critical
thinking and to embrace the challenge
and to run
run head first and and it sounds like
there's a lot of parallelism to
what you experienced going into perhaps
one of the most difficult units in the
idf and one of the most
prestigious units to running a startup
am i right
yeah i mean there's i'm
i'm a pretty analytical person i like to
sit down and think through problems
but there comes a time where you need to
just run through a wall
and i think that's like one of the
things that going through you know the
israeli navy seals really helps you like
you can you can think about every aspect
of a problem and you can have a perfect
strategy
occasionally you're just going to come
up against an obstacle and you need to
get through it in whatever way possible
and i think that's a piece that you know
it's not something you can teach someone
or tell
someone they can only learn it on their
own like in in here you say
like by your feet you have to experience
it yourself you have to push yourself to
your limits and understand that like
there's more that you can do you don't
have to succumb to the stress pressure
or whatever's in front of you at the
moment
right now that makes all sense i i'm
looking thinking back to some
experiences i had
i came from from 8200 i wish i came from
i can experience like the navy seals and
unfortunately i probably couldn't get in
even if i
applied but uh i remember that a lot of
the times we had these struggles and we
had to develop these technologies and
we just didn't have the funds to do them
and we said okay well we need
this server we need this technology and
we need this type of person
and i would go to my commander and he
would say okay no
no and unfortunately no so good luck you
still have a week to get it done
right and and so at that point you're
saying okay there's a wall and you just
have to break it
what are some what's leadership like in
the navy seals
what what is it being a what is it like
being a combat leader
um well you know there's by the way
being a combat leader and being like a
startup leader
are two very different things and i
would actually argue that
that being a startup leader or in the
business world can actually be more
difficult in a lot of ways
um being a combat leader you know like
in the military you have a rank
you have authority like there's some
things that are given from the beginning
that make it a little bit easier
um where in the business world
especially in the israeli business world
you have to earn your
place because people will challenge you
all the time
uh and so you know at the end of the day
like
in the military yes you'll have the rank
and you'll have the position
but you need a you need to own up to it
like you need to protect your people
you need to be you know lead by example
if i had to boil it all down to like one
point it would be lead by example like
if you
if you you know if you preach to people
a certain thing you don't hold yourself
to the same standards
you'll be toast in no time because the
people won't respect you so
for me that was like the guiding light
always was
whatever i ask my teams to do or my
people to do
i better make sure that i hold myself to
that exact same standard
and if you do there's really never going
to be
complaints from from the people below
you because if if you're doing it then
why shouldn't they
right if you're if you're the higher
rank if you're the person who should
have the better benefits better things
like they have no reason to complain
right and i think one of the very
special things also about
these different amazing units in the idf
is that
a lot of the times the commanders are
the ones who are doing the
heavy lifting early on especially i know
in my unit and i'm sure
i'm sure also in the navy seals that the
people that are promoted to that are
commanding and they're leading the teams
are people that were perhaps the best
soldiers and the best that both mentally
and physically
and emotionally and so i'm definitely
sure that what about
tackling it's a different type of
challenge you know when you take a team
that is tired that is beaten down and
now you have
to take that metal bar and run into the
sea
and throw it it's a very different task
than
guiding somebody to work late to deploy
a new version or
fix a bug it must be very different
yeah i mean of course um look it's one
of the one of the good
we talked about the differences between
business leadership and combat
leadership
in the military you you one of the one
of the advantages is that everybody has
a very clear
common mission which is another very
important aspect of leadership it's like
right
business all the time about like what is
your you know what's the business's uh
mission statement and what are you about
and like that's that is an attempt to
you know solidify a group around a
common cause
in the military you have that built in
it's like okay we all know what we're
here for we're here especially in israel
right we're here to make sure that
the country survives to next year
um so you know it's about
making everybody understand that that's
what they're they're there for
uh the the risk and the circumstances
are obviously
uh a lot more significant in in a combat
role
and and so you know that that helps in
some ways too because you become a lot
closer to the people you're around like
the the brothers
that you build and the fraternity of the
teams that you work with
um you know even to this day like i
obviously have a lot of good friends who
weren't in the military but friends who
did serve especially
friends who served you know on the front
line it doesn't matter if they were
special forces or not
um there's a different kind of like
connection there again
that's no disrespect to anyone who
didn't serve in those roles but
um there's there's something there that
you just can't
recreate in the outside world and even
in the business world like it's
very difficult to do that 100 my father
was a pilot
i guess maybe 40 years ago in the air
force and
not a week goes by where he doesn't
mention and an amazing friend that he
had in the course as if
as if they did a program together last
week and
and and you can you can feel the bond
that people are creating this lifelong
partnership which
which is just it's just phenomenal you
had a short stint
in venture capital something that that
not a lot of entrepreneurs get
uh and you're as young as you are so
was it how was that was it was it fun
was it enlightening
and did you benefit from that towards
the next startup
yeah absolutely um it was
first of all i think as of most of like
the
venture capitalists usually come from an
entrepreneurial role of some kind so
like
i think that's incredibly important um
to be
to have been on the other side to see
what the startup is like you look at
things a lot differently on that side
than when you're on the
entrepreneur's side you really like you
can see when a startup is maybe
you know extending the truth a little
bit or uh
you know things pop out at you that that
maybe they didn't before we were like
okay
i know i'm sure that these guys are
having this problem and just by the way
that they're speaking about it
um so it's invaluable experience and
then now back on the entrepreneur's side
it's also very
very valuable because now you know when
you go to pitch a vc you know what
they're looking for you know how busy
they are you know how like
sometimes their attention spans can just
be completely uh
too short to really listen to you so you
know kind of where to harp in and where
to focus and it
it's certainly like incredible i i
recommend that both sides do both roles
i think it'll just be more productive
for everyone um
when i was doing that role at leer it i
felt from the entrepreneurs as well that
they appreciated it as well like having
especially in corporate venture capital
because that's that's typically where
you don't get like entrepreneurs
uh in like a vc again like i was saying
usually
they have some entrepreneurial
experience um
in a corporate venture capital world not
a lot of them have their own
entrepreneurial experience so it was
because they're coming in from
internally within the organization
yeah um like i was kind of an out and i
didn't say i was only at lear for two
and a half years but
a lot of entrepreneurs who are acquired
either move you know they stay
in the operations role of running that
business or eventually they phase out
um i you know i i grew the team within
lear
of exo and then eventually joined and
helped launch the innovation
organization and took over the
the venture capital part um but that was
uh
unique or definitely not the norm i
would say
wow nori i want to thank you for
being so generous with your time really
really wonderful
and before we go i have to ask you for
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself i'm particularly
curious
to hear to hear what you have to say and
because of you because
because of your extraordinary experience
um i would say
competitive is number one most people
who uh
do i have to explain them or just give
you the words i if you can
if you can explain in short sentences i
would love that yeah
most people who know me know that i'm
extremely competitive about everything
and i joke including about who's more
competitive so
that's that's one we're gonna we're
gonna save this competition for the next
episode because uh
we have a competition going on here yeah
um
disciplined i'd say number two uh where
again like very especially in
entrepreneurship and obviously in the
military like
being disciplined to yourself not just
the outside world like whole again
holding yourself to standards like
even when you tell people a certain
thing like hey you got to wake up at
this time you got to do this this and
this
a lot of times people aren't going to be
there to see you or do it and
it's you know still important to hold
yourself to the same standards because
you know it's not about it's not about
actually doing those things it's about
the mentality of like
here's what we're going to do right
um and then three i'd say dedicated
um something else that drives me a lot
is when i when i get into something i'm
in it
you know fully um so that's that's like
i guess number three
nori i i knew you wouldn't disappoint
with those three words
thank you very very much by the way i
think that those three words didn't come
up
in any of the other 250 episodes and and
and it's because this was a very special
episode
one that's very dear to my heart because
as i traverse along my journey
especially in palo alto sometimes it's
it's not
easy to explain the experience of being
in an organization like the idf and it's
and it's also different i think from a
lot of other military experiences as
well i have friends who served in
different
militaries this innovation through
necessity this discipline this
being you know i remember when i
enlisted and the first week that i
enlisted i came as 19 straight from palo
alto i was
doing a year there with with professor
danieli i had a 19 year old girl
who was screaming at me for forgetting
to tie my shoes a certain way and i
remember that moment that it just dawned
on me that okay
this is a new reality and we're gonna do
some great things and it was a fantastic
experience
nori thank you very much it was a
pleasure
thank you thanks for having me again
good luck
you